what's the what's like what's your
favorite conspiracy that you've
entertained thus far okay so did you
watch that did you watch that Tim Dylan
episode I got 25 minutes in by the way
okay the end the end is the craziest
[ __ ] it basically he had this girl on
that like talks she reports a lot on
Epstein and and I don't know
billionaires hold on I can I think I can
get her name real quick cuz she yeah
anyways she he asked her about
coronavirus and what she thinks about
the whole thing and and she said that
you know the government is kind of using
it as an excuse to take these policies
that they're trying to implement mmm
these programs that surveillance
programs hmm like idea land and so they
can track so they can track people
essentially and just rebranding them to
be just to say that they're fighting or
helping the fight against coronavirus
with me really they were they were what
Whitney Webb sorry yeah Whitney Webb and
I don't know I don't know if she's an
expert or not
she seemed she seemed to be pretty in
the know but obviously I was taking
everything with a grain of salt but the
one thing that she said yes she said
that the government is using these
programs that they were already trying
to implement and other rebranding the
masks coronavirus program so that people
will be more accepting of them what
really they're just surveillance stuff
Rayo kind of scary yeah and then she
goes into this report that was written
by I think Eric Schmidt help helped
write it who was the you know he was in
charge of Google now he's in charge of
alphabet which is Google's parent
company or whatever yeah and this report
came out via a Freedom of Information
Act it had was released to the public
and is basically a report on AI mmm-hmm
and how we can how we can get ahead of
China in like the upcoming industrial
revolution which is all gonna be like a
I yeah and the only way we can do that
is by becoming China but even even more
so so like implementing you know all
their surveillance measures but like x 2
to the enth degree the only way yeah
yeah scared the [ __ ] out of me
yeah and that was the only that was the
conspiracy theory that I was like
damn that one i-i'll I buy into a little
bit just because well two things one do
you know that you know how China's
trying to recreate the Silk Road have
you looked into that at all no basically
the drug website no no no like like that
[ __ ] but I was like damn then sick
damn bitcoins you probably get Molly
online again [ __ ] yeah dude we can buy
with my H online again this is what's up
dude Thank You China thank you dude that
Chinese Molly be hittin oh no it's the
so I believe that the route that they're
creating I think that explains why in
the like the Widger region why they're
like creating all those internment camps
because basically I think they have some
trade deal with man is like a Middle
Eastern country they're just creating a
trade route that sort of mimics the Silk
Road on steroids and it will like their
global production and ability to
distribute will be [ __ ] insane and
will be on the eastern hemisphere and it
will have no requirement for coming to
America so basically China is just
developing their own independence from a
industry and an economic standpoint so
they're not reliant on us just because
they export iPhones to us that we won't
[ __ ] matter they'll they'll do it
everywhere else so that I guess America
doesn't really have trade power over
them I don't know this is all I'm not
saying this is fact this is just some
[ __ ] I've seen in red yeah it's scary
man no it is and so the idea that some
government people feel like oh in order
for us to compete we have to crush the
common person we have to crush their
concept or Rhys reset their concept of
freedom or what that looks like is a
some [ __ ] and and I saw like UC Irvine
is developing some quote app for vaccine
tracking and stuff and it like as try to
be positioned as like this
like yeah whatever and you know what's
bad is I've had this car I'm saying is a
lot of the stuff was already in the
works
yeah yeah for coronavirus even came
along and now they're like oh no this is
a coronavirus thing we just started
working on this hmm mm-hmm
well here's the thing that didn't excite
me I feel so like I just feel so stupid
right now I mean yeah but whatever man
we [ __ ] we've I just feel like a
drunk uncle at a party well thirty days
then you don't you don't see man they're
saying that though we're not saying that
I just you know do with 30 days in
alright we've talked about all the jokes
now it's time to [ __ ] let's get to
some scary [ __ ] you know
this freaked out a little bit together
man it's like a healthy trip you know
what I mean it's just like doing a
little bit like a little bit of heavy
shrooms yeah yeah yeah Oh stimulate some
conversation some people will call us
dumb it's okay we'll take the hit for
that are you not actually on terms right
now no no I mean shroom chocolate this
morning not and I don't want to [ __ ]
freak people out but I do think it's
worth discussing right or am I wrong am
I wrong no you're right you're right I
need to start telling like be honest
yeah you can tell me the stuff I'll shut
the [ __ ] up if you think it was the one
that brought it up fair fair fair I just
think that you know someone is gonna try
to take advantage of the situation i
i'll never be able to speak to the
gravity in terms of like you know
accuracy of tests and all these things
that people want to contest you know I'm
never I'm not in a million years saying
it's a hoax people have [ __ ] died
from this thing people have genuinely
suffered in in large amounts you know
and I think about all those people in
China who you know could may have died
and they've met it's not been discussed
it's just been sort of hushed away and I
think like the bigger thing I take away
from all this is like if it ends up
being true that you know there's this
[ __ ] power that'd be you know that's
bigger than us and has zero regard for
human life and some of this conspiracy
is [ __ ] true in some capacity it's
[ __ ] dude it's
it's so bleak I don't want that [ __ ] to
be true I want someone to come out and
be like now it's [ __ ] because
whatever and I will gladly accept that
yeah reading some of this [ __ ] I'm like
dude what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] we're
like it makes you feel [ __ ] helpless
yeah and we're all just just little
puppet yeah we're all just like little
things in the system
you